humour vous avez mis 7 ouais je suis
drôle
vous avez mis 9 sur 10 oui et réparti 8
sur 10
j'ai hâte de voir la note de reparti qui
a dit
t'inquiète pas j'étais honnête ah
d'accord qu'est-ce
que tu as dit ah oui bah écoutez ça se
voit je suis magnifique ça soit oui
c'est vrai que ça se voit arrêter et ces
deux familles se faisant la langue et
c'est très bas ça vous va très bien ça
me vient de ma grand-mère elle a une
sauce sur la langue alors
mais tu l'as toujours
il a pas eu non il y a pas toujours
réussi
à cause de c'est à cause des dents hein
du cheveu
à mon avis je risque d'avoir un cheveu
sur la langue le Guinard
S
une forêt sur la longueur
honnêteté vous avez mis 10 je suis du je
suis d'une honnêteté intellectuelle
irréprochable et répartit je trouve que
vous avez été un petit peu optimiste
entre 0 et 2 mais bon
Béatrice apparence suite tout le monde
s'est mis
j'ai pas de complexe
humour 8
pourtant tu es pas drôle très drôle
[Applaudissements]
en anglais qui par exemple en français
donc ça doit être ça on va mettre ça
honnêtement bravo
et reparti 0
Delphine Delphine tu te fous de ma
gueule
humour c'est bien quoi humour t'amusette
avec des gens je suis très drôle et mes
amis disent que je suis très marrante
très drôle
[Rires]
on va venir à toi
Guillaume non arrête tu es magnifique
alors j'accepte pas ta note en apparence
typique je domine
il est très beau c'est mon ami
alors tu as mis cinq tumeur
honnêteté tu as mis deux là je suis
d'accord
[Applaudissements]
je suis d'accord
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai raison moi je ne suis pas du tout
drôle mais en revanche et humour je me
suis dit que j'étais très bon public
donc voilà
honnêteté
plus en fait je pense que je suis très
honnête mais je trouvais que 10 c'était
beaucoup presque parfois j'ai pas été
honnête dans ma vie mais je ne sais pas
je m'en souviens il est répartissait
un petit mot j'aurais mis un petit peu
mon humour plus on était plus en
répartie plus on apparence si vous
voulez faites ça bah je vais faire ça
alors
Raymond non alors n'accepte pas mon ami
mon frère
tu es magnifique tu as des pieds
magnifiques
arrêtez d'être gentil je suis éclaté
c'est la vérité
humour je te mets 9
c'est bien
honnête je te mets un
[Applaudissements]
je vais menti
voilà que sa mère elle est partie 11 sur
je te mets plus en apparence plus son
humour beaucoup moins honnêteté et on
répare la répartie ne veut pas dire que
je vais dire quelque chose d'intelligent
ou d'intéressant la répartie veut dire
que je voulais dire quelque chose
merci pour ta définition
[Musique]
je suis pas d'accord
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je suis d'accord surtout vous voyez
emmerdeur emmerdant 11
je me suis un peu surnommé apparence
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous n'avez pas l'air convaincu en
disant ça chaque année
je te mets 9 on peut pas mettre que des
notes enfin être un peu ce que je te
livre
c'est bizarre bah non
honnêteté envers nous aussi pour
conversatou ouais non mais je trouve que
c'est les notes correctes moi pour moi
c'est pour moi c'est presque des bonnes
notes au conseil de classe
comment vous estimez votre personne
je vais démarrer par une partie j'ai
démarré par réparti c'est parti
[Rires]
je crois qu'on peut arrêter
donc moi en apparence je me suis mis
quatre
[Applaudissements]
je me suis mis quatre en apparence
malhonnête humour je me suis mis 7
honnêteté
je me suis
trompé
je me suis dit non je me suis mis cinq
crédit
toute la journée je suis un monstre bah
alors je vais vous donner mes traits
c'est mieux déjà on va passer tout de
suite à l'humour
je fais croire que me trouver
minimum 10 min
sur l'honnêteté
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]